der fünfte karte mit youtube und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute spielen wir wie im titel schon
gesehen haben ein spiel für die ganze
familie herz besteht bei dem einer
familie fett und zwar youtube oder
schöne plätze schön klingt und da ist
halt mit dabei die youtuber oder
philosophie da wirklich schwierig weil
die bilder sind schon ähnlich sonne
direkt schwierig mit ein zeigt dass
youtube oder philosophie studiert ok
alles der arbeiter ihr verzweifelter hat
von youtube und der heißt andré weisheit
studierte philosoph
okay er kommt zur nächsten möglichkeit
leute von youtube der philosoph ist die
jetzt macht schon sinn smaghi
verstolperten start und die fed im
verlauf der sechs teile vom freund sagen
kann ich meine fotos gespeichert und für
sie ohne inhalt
leider falsch dort irgendeine haupt
gestreckte version von egl kenne deine
prioritäten auf jeden fall das ist
tatsächlich ein lösung durch 250 beraten
oder wie für hundefreunde bücher öffnet
durch das spiel für die ganze familie
friedrich nietzsche denke ich kurz vor
seinem zusammenbruch im jahr wenn tut
meine videos von ihr erstellten
schwarzen schwan lang gibt es in die
fünfte oder willst du für 315 cool aber
besteht club aber achtung
aber warum ist schon eine abweichung von
der schusswaffe schusswaffen muss schon
gesehen haben zu dem zeitpunkt wo er die
besucher ein bisschen englisch
119 108 und aktives urteilte
[Musik]
beispielsweise elektro liegt in
frankreich den 80ern wirklich populär so
knoblich karten zu tragen ich habe alle
gemacht dann ja soviel bisher bloss bei
der man steht das 32
als nächstes wird um eine richtige
nummer also hoffe dafür kann sein dass
ein gehirn ist von der alleine
überforderung einfach explodiert dort
hat formulars konterspiel das ist dass
sich das unternehmen alles damit läuft
der wechselkandidat von youtube oder
viele so der eindruck der 105 kind zum
schon auf dieses jahr sein
in berlin und hisste
klar ist auch wieder ein bisschen
konservativer es kommt also meine kleine
also dass die personen den alle anderen
abonnenten hat ist eigentlich haben die
auflösung von fotos ist auch genau dies
auch sehr gute 4 k fotografie dvf
8-klatsche glücklich mit philosophischen
text und bild ausgewählt worden
aber auch noch geister los alles klar
leute das auch von diesem video
vielleicht der beschreibung verlinkt
oder einfach auf youtube.com / eltern ja
vielleicht mitmachen so viel habe ich
heute hast du geschlafen wird durch
bessere bilder auf befehle findet bilder
und krieg kommt nächsten mal erreichten
nur um erneut bevor sie zu wenige gibt
noch einen schauder und zwar an der ohne
heck danke dafür dass eine
benachrichtigung an gemacht hat und wenn
ja unter vertrag wird einfach die glocke
von einem kanal so dass die generation
bekommt und kommentiert wenn ihr fertig
seid dann nehmen sie auch an dieser
verlosung 200 chance
in einem video der wursttheke